well this is an outstanding standoff of
patriotism
following the national anthem luis
oviedo of the pirates alex blandino of
the reds
it's the first time that blandino's
cracked a smile
i've never seen it last this long this
is great this is awesome though
i think conroy has just now gotten wind
of what's taking place
he gestured to both of them they're not
going anywhere
it's over let's go chris conroy is
saying
oh lo omiedo gave up oh
valiant effort we'll get him tomorrow
meanwhile
baseball mitch keller getting the start
tonight in six games he's two and three
with a 6.29 and 24 and a third innings
pitched
mitch has got some good stuff i like it
so far throwing his fastball
and defoe that's a cross to get the out
now winker who has been
their best hitter this year that's all
right mitch keller is going to go get
him
i broke his bat and fraser able to
track it down so two quick ouch for
keller that's a good sign for his
evening thus far
castillos is fourth in the national
league and hitting at 3 16. nine home
runs he's driven in 20 he's also fourth
in ops
gotta put in play again frazier nice
friendly hop
and a six pitch inning for mitch keller
you'd love to see that tyler malley
who's been great on the year
o'malley is very capable the one thing
that he's really excelled at this year
is getting left-handed hitters out
here's the pitch swing and a miss good
fastball from mali down and away from
kai tom and he swings right through it
phillip evans
first pitch swing and the flip o'malley
works around a couple of walks
eugenio suarez suarez shoots it to right
that's got carrie and that's gone hey
eugenio suarez
a solo shot in the reds on top one to
nothing
now stay behind the baseball never try
to pull a high pitch
and suarez is able to negotiate this
fastball this is one where
keller gets it down basically in the
center of the zone leading off for the
box
is pirates catcher jacob stallings
and stallings trying to return serve
deep to left
jacob stallings with the home run
that's what a good catcher does he comes
in and picks you up
you know what mitch keller i'll take
care of this we'll even it back up
love to see it look at that 103.3 off
the bat
27 degrees 409 feet
and home run number two for the guy who
got to bat clean up for the first time
in his career yesterday
i love it should have had him in there
today so he got something off speed was
left up looked like one of those backup
sliders that a lot of times you get away
with as a pitcher but not when jacob
stallings is swinging the lumber
if you could ever throw a double play
ball this would be a good time for it
now's the time
since el runs well though well let's see
phillip evans oh wow nicely started by
philip evans
beautiful job joe you got the call you
got the line of that baseball too
oh that's as slick as it gets right
there that was a tremendous
good vibes swings
breaking ball hung a bit looped in the
air that's going to fall on
in i think jesse winker has broken by
far the most bats among the reds that
sounded like the wood might have given
way again but allows him to get the base
knock
and winker who's been one of the best
road hitters in baseball
mike mustakas and he loops that one into
left center field base hit winker given
the wave
tom from left fires in it rolls to third
winker scores castellanos to second and
there it is
first pitch ambush mike mustakas reds on
top 2-1
well he gets a pitch right down broadway
i mean you couldn't put one on a t any
better spot than right there
maybe keller was looking for a pitch on
the inner part of the plate hoping to
get a ground ball but mustache was able
to put the barrel on it
mustache measures his lead now tyler
naked in the
eyes of the pirates this guy may look
big and invincible right now
and he bashes that one to right field
that's going to get down all the way to
the wall
castillano scores mustache stop sign at
third a standing
rbi double delivered by tyler naquin
and the reds have a couple of runs in on
the inning it's three to one now
keller's got to contend with tucker
barnhart
down target barnhart shoots it
high in the air deep left center the
deepest part of the park
and it skips to the fence misplayed by
tom
mustakas and aqua nearly side by side
cross
just about simultaneously and barnhart
delivers as he has
most of the year a gap double opposite
way
it's a 5-1 reds lead dwayne underwood
junior coming in
he's had a nice start to the season 12
games so far he's 1-1 with a 3-9-4 and
16 index pitch
he has to face nick senzel major chance
here now the reds already cruising
four runs in for a four run lead but
bases loaded
one out and that is spanked into right
field base hit
barnhart scores former given the wave he
scores on a slide two run single nick
senzelle
it's a six run inning the reds seven
the pirates one knows he's getting a
breaking ball
you can't pull that pitch and he ends up
getting a base hit driving the couple in
castillanos come on dwayne come get him
right here not a boy
here's the change up to strikeout
castellanos
tucker barnhart's had himself a strong
knight shot a two-run double
opposite gap and he yanks this one
right field corner barnhart shoots up to
second
oh look like it caught the lip down the
right field line because when it hit the
edge of that grass that extends almost
to the
corner in the wall it kicked dead
towards the right field corner
kyle farmer barnhart a decent lead
and that is smoke through the whole base
hit stop sign in third
a two hit night for kyle farmer i sure
like his short swing i mean he just gets
right to the baseball
malley has a hit and a walk
backhand pick newman
not in time barnhart scores 8-1
reds rbi for the pitcher and the rbi
comes not by the swing of the bat but by
the hustle from home to first base
the reds with runners at first and third
base for tyler naquin
it's crushed to right field fair or foul
it clangs off the pole
tyler naquin crushes a three-run
bomb 11-1 the reds are
routing the pirates well the only
question about that one is that he hit
it so hard was it hooking we couldn't
tell from where we were sitting but it
just stayed
just enough to just about halfway up
that pole that baby was
launched senzel first and second nobody
out
the pitch that is ripped to right
down basic farmer scores
glandino to third rbi double nick senzel
has two hits and three rbis tonight
12-1 okay i'm loving his stroke right
now
castillanos certainly had his moments
he's one of the few not in the hit
parade tonight
that makes everybody happy get in there
there's the first hit for castillatos
he'll add a couple of ribs
glandino scores senzelles scores
castellanos
head man into second couple of more runs
for the reds
14-1 a demolition
at pnc park two away and it brings up
ben gamel
a lot of joy in mudville for the reds
today
crushing these pirates payoff
ball game reds they
route the pirates one of the biggest
blowouts
ever for cincinnati in pittsburgh
they've won eight straight